better light than pregnant it's my
philosophy you know I found it the Bible
if I post a book I wrote felt B I'd be a
Oh
anyway I literally just got off a plane
from Louisville Kentucky as part two or
hey USA I'm not giving any spoilers away
except this game up a huge spoiler no if
ever actually paying attention to this
series you already know this anyway its
fourth of July for most of you right now
it's America's birthday Independence Day
Will Smith I love history I love my
country I love Big Willie style so I
thought today I would give you one
unknown fact about each of the 50 United
States of America let's go Alabama's
state bird is a sweaty pigeon in Alaska
whales aren't allowed to wear belly
chains Arizona has experienced the most
UFOs unexpectedly farting orphans how do
they get down there why are there so
kasi unexplained Roswell is the home of
the famous Pig Newton a giant pig that
looks like a Fig Newton California is
for Glover's Daniel Glover specifically
also Donald Glover Colorado State Flag
is a performance place in Connecticut
they've officially outlawed pleated
pants though is Best Buy employees Pro
tested in Delaware every year in July
they have the statewide contest called
who is the most sad ed States has been
the reigning champion since 2009 yes not
fun to be around
flutter state motto is Bleacher gumbo
Bloo Blee blah barf
paint fart down in Georgia in 1996 they
tried to vote a cheesecake in as their
senator to be fair it was a strawberry
cheesecake it had a Napoleon complex
Hawaii installed the Internet in their
state May of 2014 in Idaho in 1975 a
local woman proclaimed that she had been
fondled by a ghost vacuum it sucked
every year in Illinois on October 23rd
citizens locked themselves in their
bedrooms and cry
Indiana was originally named by a really
pervy settler who was really proud of
getting in dianna this lucky barkeep
Iowa is known as the Hawkeye State
why because its founder got really step
on this and ate the eyes out of his pet
hawk the weirdest part is he didn't have
a pet Hawk in Kansas everyone has nine
toes and ten toasts if toast ten times
before they can eat their dinner
middle America Kentucky's most popular
cuisine is pop-tarts in Louisiana it is
legal to marry anything just by touching
I'll never remember our anniversary in
Maine no one has a bubble Marilyn has
great Bloody Marys and crabs the
Massachusetts state motto is we're not
close-minded we just locked the door la
la la la la la la la Jake a chef's job
in Michigan on April 6 every College of
graduate takes a second to look at
themselves in the mirror and say why in
Minnesota progressive is considered a
swear word Mississippi can't stand her
mother Mississippi talk about milf in
Missouri lazy eyes are celebrated
Montana had that terrible
mechanical-bull massacre of 1997 in
Nebraska everything is actually black
and white in 1997 old hampshire went on
this TLC reality show called haha we
guess this is educational and they
reinvented themselves into New Hampshire
New Jersey State Representative is a
pair of jeggings in New Mexico sadly no
good burritos
we found new york post several employees
are paid in breakfast sandwiches north
carolina is the home of share the
flamboyant watch salesman
chef archetype of a mark Tom hi again
North Dakota has the most three-legged
dogs per capita in Ohio yawning is a
form of complimenting someone Oklahoma
they're really not okay
everyone has tuberculosis in Oregon
Pennsylvania has a religion called
flamin hot cheetos rhode island people
in south dakota are very sensitive to
being farted on tennessee is known as
the Volunteer State because everyone
that lives there is to fake legs and
needed a plethora of all tears to help
them get around Texas outlaw chaise
lounges in 1990 it was a debate and you
talk beanie babies are still a huge
thing don't tell them just let them have
it
Vermont we get it you love to ski in
Virginia Plan B is called coffee in
Washington dry cat food is not allowed
in West Virginia hating yourself as the
new black does that face this as their
whole slogan everyone in Wisconsin has a
lactose issue they're just super
repressed why you'll make
there you go there's a fact about all 50
states that you may or may not have
already known happy 4th of July
happy American birthday I don't nice go
over and check out youtube.com slash
astronauts want a TV and never sub went
up yesterday there's my favorite episode
granted of all three episodes but it's
really good at night want you to watch
it please